Speaker 1: So we're getting closer and closer
really to the start of the 2022 midterms and one
of the signals that will be important in 2022,
about 2024, if we're continuing to wonder as we
are about the future of Trumpism as something that
has the Republican Party in a vice grips for lack
of a better term is how people that are aligned
with Trump do in 2022 versus people who are not
aligned with Trump due in 2022. And we have to
that end, a very, very interesting new report from
Bloomberg, which looked at fundraising for various
Republicans that have not been in the pro-Trump
wing. Let's take a look at this and see if we can
learn anything from it. Trump's picks lag Cheney
and Republican incumbents in fundraising. Cheney,
of course, being Lynne Cheney. Liz Cheney. Sorry,
Cheney, Upton and Herrera Butler voted to
impeach Donald Trump. Trump PAC hasn't donated
to their opponents. Three House Republicans
targeted by former President Donald Trump
raised more money in the third quarter than
his hand-picked candidates to defeat them,
according to the FEC filings. Representatives
Liz Cheney of Wyoming, Fred Upton of Michigan
and Jaime Herrera Beutler of Washington were
among 10 House Republicans who infuriated Trump
by voting against him during his second
impeachment proceeding. So far, Republican donors
haven't followed him in backing their challengers.
So already two important bits of news here no one
voting to impeach Trump in that second impeachment
trial. Despite what Trump and other Trumpists said
doesn't seem to have been a death blow to those
individuals, at least so far, they're raising more
money and No. Two. An endorsement from Trump in
these particular cases, at least, isn't actually
helping the opponents that these individuals raise
more money now. We've still got a while, right?
These are primary races, we've still got a while.
We'll see what happens. But so far, both of the
claims you're going down if you voted to impeach
me doesn't seem like it. And no, to my endorsement
is going to rocket people to the winner's circle.
Not not actually happening so far. Let's continue.
Trump has yet to endorse candidates running
against the other six Republican incumbents
who voted to impeach him on a charge of inciting
the Jan. six insurrection at the U.S. Capitol.
But his vow to fight them has worried Republican
officials. Republicans need to flip only a handful
of seats to gain control of the House in 22
and weakening incumbent seeking reelection by
funding. Primary challenges would complicate
that task. Another Republican who voted for
impeachment. Representative Anthony Gonzalez, said
in September that he wouldn't seek reelection. His
Trump endorsed challenger Max Miller, took in six
hundred ninety five thousand dollars, including
half a million of personal funds he loaned for his
campaign in Ohio 16th District. Miller also got
$5000 from Save America, Trump's leadership PAC
now. Listen to this. This is very interesting,
though Trump's committees had $102 million
in the bank at the end of June. So far,
he's done little to spread the wealth around Save
America. His leadership PAC has channeled $5000
to some incumbent Republican senators. These
endorsed, including John Boozman, Rand Paul
and Tim Scott. But some of the House candidates
he's backing have yet to see any donations
through the end of September. That includes
Harriett Hagerman, a Wyoming attorney who won
Trump's endorsement to take on Cheney. Hegemann
raised three hundred and one thousand dollars,
and Cheney has topped one point five million
each quarter. So it's just it's it's very, very
lopsided there. Herrera Butler raised five hundred
and twenty three thousand. She topped the four
hundred and fifty thousand raised by U.S. Army
vet Joe Kent. That's closer for sure and upped in
the voting to impeach Trump. Incumbent raised 292
K, topping one hundred and fifteen thousand for
Steve Khara, who earned Trump's endorsement
in September. This this is interesting in a
number of different ways. First of all, it would
be great to just see them see themselves, see them
tear themselves apart. And as is pointed out in
the article, and as we can sort of think about,
these could be very weakening challenges, primary
challenges to the incumbents, every indication so
far. So so let's think through all of the
different ways in which Trump and Trumpists
have been wrong, they've been wrong. That voting
to impeach Trump in 2020 was going to destroy
their chances in 2022. So far, they're doing
fine. They're had. They're raising more money,
they seem to be doing fine. So they were wrong
about that. Trump saying you're out doesn't seem
to have the power that Trump hoped that it would
have no to Trump. Hand picking a replacement
also doesn't seem to be doing that much
for the replacements. Now, arguably,
these challengers might be doing even worse had
they not been endorsed by Trump. We don't know.
Number three, even Trump doesn't seem that
motivated to actually help these people, at
least not financially, as he has barely donated to
any of these hand-picked challengers so far now.
Maybe it's too early or that although primaries
are starting to come up for some of these folks,
maybe it's that Trump doesn't really believe that
they're going to win, or it might be that this is
just part of the grift. Trump's raising money,
supposedly to help put the right Republicans,
and Trump always says, We're going to get the
rhinos out. The Republicans in name only are going
to go out. But it may be that the real reason for
fundraising is just the grift collecting money,
paying off campaign. That's all of the things
that we talked about Trump doing back when he was
raising money to fight election fraud, which, by
the way, we're going to talk about tomorrow again.
In some of these races, fundraising might matter
less than in other parts of the country Wyoming,
for example, which is such a small population.
It's less about having the most money to do
advertising. The population is tiny. It's more
about news, narratives and personality stuff.
And maybe endorsements even would make a
difference. But in a lot of these races,
whoever raises more money ends up winning. So
we're going to follow these. But so far, Trump
doesn't seem to have that golden touch. And also
Trump saying, Get them out of here. They are bad.
We need to remove them. That also doesn't seem to
be damaging. A lot of these people will see Trump
loves to claim his great record on endorsements.
It's actually not so good. Actually, not so good